look down look down don't look right at
the screen we can't we try it's just to
demoscene the singing sly whose bright
idea was that probably a guy who gave
shall fail that hat come on you guys
it's not that bad per se but Ross oho
okay okay okay look down look down don't
look right at the screen harsh of you
guys
it's brentalfloss I seen Dennis approval
for 601 your punishment has officially
begun
you know what that means probably
something catches like a cat what what
um hey boss hey what you doing well
singing is that what you call it yeah
it's wonderful I actually been
channeling Russell Crowe by listening to
his latest album and I gotta tell you
he's changing the music world forever
yeah for good or bad what quick meeting
everybody oh oh me too
we can't have him in the review you
think I don't know that we have to get
rid of him it's like a musical
Armageddon the movie or the event does
it matter
oh think I got an idea floss we've been
talking and we realized that we would
like the role much better if you played
it as dr. Mario we would shut up see how
it ties in so much more to your with
lyric series well that sounds awesome I
actually have a dr. Mario costume with
me right if only it were that simple you
see we really want you to get in
character and that require you going to
medical school well how long is that tic
only a couple days it does if he does
that again you can shoot him
so go ahead
floss go in there and get your medical
degree awesome that's a great idea
well see you guys in a few days oh and
if anyone tells you otherwise they're
liars aah
shall we start this review properly why
start now
a little background in 1862 Victor Hugo
published his magnum opus the story of
criminal turned Saint Jean Valjean with
a title that can be roughly translated
as the miserable ones the dispossessed
or even the victims lame is a lab was a
worldwide commercial success though
initially a critical failure with
critics taking issue with novels many
digressions broad characters and even
gasps its revolutionary spirit sweeping
book sales in the next century and a
half
blame is would become multiple film
adaptations a TV miniseries
or radio drama fighting games okay and
the buccal which well go ahead Paul
this story of the 1832 June rebellion in
Paris was forever transformed in
collective consciousness when
claude-michel schönberg and company
decided that this tale would make a
great musical and became known as one of
the single greatest musicals of the late
20th century then Tom Hoover decided
that this should become a blockbuster
movie in 2012 and became known as the
single strangest execution of the 21st
century but that's not necessarily a bad
thing
dan seeing how we're all late as fans
and how it mixes our house technique and
musical techniques we figure this would
be the ideal combo so let's see how some
of the most celebrated music of all time
is represented now who's the two for six
over your time is up and your paroles
begun will let the cute going through
puberty out of the glee club and I'm
self
do not forget my name that's Russell
Crowe playing Javert a guard turned
inspector becomes obsessed with a
prisoner named Jean Valjean played by
Hugh Jackman and what terrible crime did
Valjean commit to make him so obsessed
he stole a loaf of bread he did what an
excusable in a time of rape and murder
bread stealing will not be tolerated
critic all calm down have you ever had
French bread no that you wouldn't
understand
sistahs child was close to death we were
stopping stop again and yes it's almost
pointless to talk about Russell Crowe's
horrible singing as he's already been
the butt of so many jokes I'm Yakko i
Wakko and I'm so bad but one way does
Russell Crowe's voice rub people the
wrong way because in many respects it's
actually not as bad as you may think
hear me out when you get down to it he's
in tune he knows how to phrases melodies
but he's using a different style he's
trained in rock and folk a subdued
naturalistic style musical theater is
grand and stylized and because of that
the nature of the aesthetic makes it
easy to spot a faker on top of that crew
likes to use his acting method of if I
act like I don't care maybe I can trick
you to care but in this film all the
other actors seem to have it his key
mind frame of loving to emote and convey
actual emotion Oh give me so I would not
we can't pretend all the actors sing
great especially when compared to the
stage versions say what you must don't
leave it there but the acting still
really pulls through like here while on
his parole Jean Valjean can't find any
work because of his past but a priest
played by Colm Wilkinson shows comfort
to him there is wine here to revive you
that was bred to make you strong that's
cone Wilkinson yeah it can't be why not
I can understand him he usually sounds
like Sean Connery of his lips were being
stretched by a rice picker the Kaiser a
God that nobody hears hear when I stand
at the turning off the games I mean she
must be more like there's wine here to
revive you have bread to make you throw
who you believe that man alone he is a
musical treasure I will for now Kyle but
my collection of comb Wilkinson funny
voices will not go untouched so Valjean
gets arrested for stealing silver from
the priest but the priest makes up a lie
for Valjean allowing him to be freed
this hits pretty close for our hero so
close you can practically smell his
breath my life he claims for God ah Bob
such things be Jesus guy take a few
steps back I can see the scenery you've
been chewing between your teeth yes and
the wide range of scenery is impressive
too in front of the altar back to the
hall back to the altar again back to the
hall well you can't say the pacing of
this movie is bad no no it only works if
I do it
you
so now that Valjean wants to break his
parole and turn his life around
I'm sure a good chunk of the movie is
going to be showing the process of his
transformation from outcast fugitive to
an everyday balanced citizen of France
actually he's the mayor in the next
scene wait a minute
what yeah eight years go by and he's
there no no no no nobody just goes from
runaway fugitive to being the mayor of
an entire town yeah it's usually the
other way around you're missing the
point the transformation could have been
a movie all in of itself and instead the
movie just sneezes it at us I mean look
at all these people suffering dead
bodies children starving why doesn't
somebody just say come on you lazy
bastard be mayor
you like stealing bread out of other
people's mouths that's politics in a
nutshell well maybe he's getting help
from this sister that he mentioned
earlier who's not really in the film at
all or a child or a child or child and
he or she grew up to become president
whatever you know how that's how you do
to print people out presidents so severe
having transformed into Maximus
Bonaparte the strikes fell John's
attention when he tried to settle a
factory dispute deal with this woman I
might have known the cat had claws I
might have guessed your little secret
this result in the factory worker
Fantine played by Anne Hathaway being
tossed out while Valjean is
congratulated by Javert for not being
recognized by him it seems to me we may
have met your face is not a face I would
forget uh-huh way to bring in that
Broadway training there Hugh Paul get
Paul get Paul get so Fantine goes into
the cruel cruel world selling her hair
teeth and ultimately herself so she can
support her child why hasn't she heard
she can be Mayer in the jump cut hell by
the time this movie is over she'll
probably be the queen of France next to
Belle Jon's niece or nephew president
but a second okay this leads to the big
I dream to dream performance and it's
fantastic
it's all done in one shot it keeps the
intimacy close and hathaways boys and
performance knocked it out of the park
the choice of moving the scene to after
she becomes a prostitute and not just
after she loses her job makes the moment
all the more heartbreaking as well
it carries shades of Falcon Eddie as
Joan of Arc if the rest of the film were
this passionate we would not be doing
this review in fact I think you'd be
hard-pressed to find anyone who wasn't
blown away by this scene well I'll get
it how dare you do a musical revue
without me the world has to hear my
angelic voice sheesh don't you want to
hear what I really thought about Anne
Hathaway's performance it's not bad it's
just we have enough reviewers Kyle deal
with it
I might have known my cat had claws I
might have known the bitch could fight I
might have guessed you're singing
cigarettes okay if you're going to
insult me don't do it it's song fine
I'll just say it's my turn to shine and
shut the door on you think'll be okay oh
he'll be fine I'm sure we'll get over it
I dreamed I'd be in this review I was
barely in the Moulin Rouge war
I dream they'd give me stuff to do
unlike poor Duggan's Muppets crude one I
critique at Hathaway
got evil freak for her performance
keeping the hung in one take
like that some impressive feat Broadway
actors do that night
Irina I just I was gone my ipod I'm not
trying to do a wonder take do they like
finding a perfectly nice pen
we're Russell Crowe some smooth and Ruby
I dreamt the singers white so shrill
but then wool
I dream life as shown
I know are you alright
so Valjean comes across Fantine looking
radiant in her Smeagol makeup and feels
guilty because he let his Foreman throw
her out yes you were there and turned
aside yeah how dare you left a situation
you knew nothing about a nun asked a guy
to do the job he was required to do
nevertheless Valjean does feel guilty
and takes her to the hospital where she
tells him that she has a child who needs
to be taken care of in case she dies and
then she dies oh it wasn't accurate
timing what's not good timing is that
Javert discovers Valjean after he's
confessed his true identity why did he
do that well because another man was
confused for him so incidentally being
brought to the court on the same day so
the Valjean revealed himself in the
courtroom Monsieur Javert wasn't there
so the judge for some reason let him
leave to go to the hospital where's your
vehicle up later oh that old story but
Valjean escapes and vows to look after
her daughter Cosette who lives with
Sacha Baron Cohen and Elna bottom cutter
why didn't you use their character names
because it's Sasha Baron Cohen and
Helena bonham-carter that's where they
always play there's a saucy tale rights
a little stir customers appreciate the
ball deeper I find it extremely ironic
that Cohen is doing an exaggerated
French accent in a movie where everyone
is French yet everyone else in the movie
has a British accent despite the fact
the cone is one of the few British
people there but they shake it up with
some of the more offbeat humor like oh
god are they raping Santa wouldn't that
technically be father Christmas I
thought be parent no L don't care the
raping Santa well maybe that was their
way of making it a christmas film i
could just see the ads now let miserable
a musical romp of death starvation and
raping Santa lalala but why would they
do something like that because it's
Sasha bear : and held a bottom Carter
they're all about doing shock humor like
that such is not zealotry zone Malcolm
Rachel what are you doing here
it's not a shock value that keeps them
getting higher
there's so much more like what when all
the angst is too much to take comic
relief can give you a break but who to
pick to shell out the laughs without
appearing lame or half-ass when you need
to Britt's seasons and midget folk
creepier than there's one pick for
it Sasha Baron Cohen and Helena Bonham
Carter wine to spare with crazy hair
we'll hear some starter both a little
nutty and often very you want to
see variety well too bad buddy no need
for big audition you look all over town
they can really bone it in with mr.
buttons not around Sacha Baron Cohen and
Helena Bonham Carter if you make it
easier they won't try harder grab a
costume and throw me no room they get a
tacky giggle at the plot resumes there's
a woody trying to hate them don't come
back with much more may become their own
and he said get some stable day so give
a hearty so though John comes to take a
set away who seems to take the whole
dead mother thing pretty well I dare
even say it's just glanced over but to
be fair it you are a girl you probably
be happy to somebody have Wolverine as
your father to so much so that it calls
for a song that they scotch-taped onto
the film just to get a Best Original
Song nomination Nevermore alone
Nevermore apart you have won my heart
like this
you have brought the gift of life
someone deny me
but jayveer spots the flame Valjean and
chases after him
not since I shook my head in a room with
no lights on have I seen an action scene
so well shot but luckily he has helped
out by a person he saved from a runaway
cart earlier you saved my life
Monsieur we need to play some sanctuary
this child and I we need I need to
disappear
we'll give thanks for your concern about
getting collared are you yeah Monsieur
we have to keep quiet you may not sing
like that so now John escapes Javert coz
that finds a new place to call home and
they live the rest of their days
together and that was lemmas robbed
everybody man they had a lot to cram in
there but I think he gonna get up in
it's not over yet man this that was
barely the first third the first third
hey I'm a story to fill Christopher
Nolan follow the hello there's much much
more like Javert swearing an oath to the
stars even though ironically you can
barely see the stars well at the very
least this will give more time for the
character to bloom I mean we can see the
connection between a new father and
daughter and see how their relationship
will evolve no next scene she's a
teenager and it's nine years later oh
come on I thought this was supposed to
be like the musical of emotion and
feelings it is well how it's passing
over all the essential relationships and
transformations that create drama you
can do whole entire musicals based on
one of the changes these characters go
through but instead they squeeze each
change into one song and then dumping
more characters and stories not needed
why can't they just focus on the already
heavy characters and storylines that
they have well they do
while also throwing in Mario's Eponine
Gavril smells rose for more characters
with four more story lines to add to the
jumble next you'll be telling me they're
bringing back characters they already
got rid of Jesus Christ as if we don't
have enough but that's over the original
stage show which is an adaptation of a
book the size of the Bible critic does
bring up a good point doing a film
adaptation is tricky enough already but
this is a medium transfer from a medium
transfer you go from a book which
audiences usually allowed to be Islam's
and once to a Broadway show which
audience is usually allowed to be
three hours with an intermission to a
movie which audiences usually allow two
and a half hours at most
with no intermission exactly if they
love this adaptation to work they had to
make bigger changes without being afraid
of the purist fanbase whatever
confrontation pops up they shouldn't be
expected to just run and hide its breath
applause run and hide hey guys you were
right it is easy to become a doctor I
got my medical certification in just one
day that was impossible Shh
where'd you guys go oh wait I should
stay in character oh you guys do not
forget me get up a good morning 12:01
hmm they don't seem to be here maybe
they're in the lobby coming out as a
joke here ah got it
but vie for the vampire live in Sesame
Street when Muppets don't have any blood
oh hey there why are you talking so
funny why are you talking so funny I'm
rehearsing for a musical revue in room
204 601 and I can't seem to find them
goodbye oh you guys wanted to go
musically yeah okay so we have a gritty
dark realistic musical that has tons of
characters and story to develop yes and
they tackle it in the most gritty and
realistic way Marius and Cosette meet up
and they instantly fall in love bab
stoop yeah yeah that is stupid not to
mention the love triangle that generates
between the two of them and Eponine and
let me guess the one that nobody loves
is the one that has the most development
pretty much
love love was never mind to
jingles Oh like anything not you yeah
sorry sorry guys I mean this stuff just
doesn't happen in real life it's cheesy
even on Broadway where do two people see
each other and then instantly fallen hey
I heard there's a musical revue there is
lame is Rob oh yeah
what were you guys talking about a silly
it is and people see each other in
musicals and instantly fall in love
ridiculous it's weird we're so used to
hearing that kind of song and yet when
you think about it logically it's so
obviously wrong in real life it can take
so much time just to find a good guy in
real life it can be really hard just to
tell someone hi gorgeous don't take long
cuz in a musical
who cares about logic when people can
break into song
right in real life there's no guy who
could capture my heart with one glance
in real life how could one chance
encounter lead straight to romance
lay my hasty hello and they're ready to
go pick their first baby's name ha ha ha
bulge in your blood what if we were in
that kind of song we'd look like a pair
of fools so I hear you guys are enough
each other
weren't you saying wonderful herbs
you'd be the dashing young hero and
you'd be the intriguing pungent in a way
you have to loan that kind of song cause
that's how I feel about
your specialties are you must use this
review is carrying more subplots than
the movie well at least we couldn't
possibly get any more guys guys you
won't believe what I saw no no no no no
no I was a platypus bunny
what's a platypus
don't worry whenever lady Jon in put it
hand lime colored skin yeah it had a
tail made on wet feet Wow till never
webbed feet sure it's not as impressive
as it sounds suppose this is as good a
spot as ever to take a break but we have
to do in traditional lame is style how
with a song big enough to bring people
back but not too big us to overshadow
the final song oh you mean like
one big song big enough that we leave
them all but not so big that we blow our
wall let's rock the viewers to the core
believe them longing for one more big
lie
zero things about you
laughs what a shorts militia
like going away to love to you
time to show Jones baby vampire calm
where's the critic I don't desert where
in God's name did they go got my PhD so
quickly though I got it from Russell
whoa we don't need any more help with
history year
I got it covered with my career
watch this
ears singing this one's on me
it's all one piece
one
so just a recap Paris is in the middle
of starting revolution number up team
kajillion because they don't like the
way the poor are being treated it's a
very rushed way of putting it if I put
it in song you'd say it was brilliant
Eponine sings a song about the
friendzone and Marius sings like he
swallowed an oboe to be struck to the
bone in a moment her breathless - hi
judging by his voice Mary's is going to
grow the Charlie Brown's teacher Hanna
WAP was wrong the seems wrong smart this
all builds up to the big attack led by
the peasants of the town as they set up
the barricades all over now in the stage
version the barricades are giant massive
sets truly something to behold but in
this version they're all squeezed into
tiny corners of the town allowing of
course to get nothing but countless more
close-ups because the cinematography in
this film is awful I want to feel a
motion for these people not count how
many zits they have now hold on a minute
now those shots were done so you could
feel the intimacy and the closeness of
the characters yeah besides there's a
lot of other good cinematography in this
like the crane shot the tracking shots
the still shots first off the crane
shots are only done the beginning or end
of scene that's it not to mention they
all look like they're from a Pixar
version of Fiddler on the Roof second
the tracking shots are great but the
ending never allows us enough time to
show them in fact most of the editing in
this movie is so rabid that you can
barely even follow what's going on come
on it can't be as bad as all that no no
I enjoy the cinematography I have
something to sing about doesn't matter
he has that a song yet sorry is somebody
doing a musical review Sholes film is
told in a language with syntax and
grammar some shots are adverbs others
are pronouns still lovers conjunctions
you get the idea every shot has its
place every shot has its place if you're
matting the hands don't be so lazy and
lame every shot will look terribly dull
if a face feels the frame look how the
camera Wiggles and jolts and it all
looks the same and so it has been and so
it is return on the gray
don't hop Eisenstein the filter shots so
muddy boring don't stand the test of
time shots
hotel directors how to shoot movies make
them on home with student films at least
tell them how to shoot how to shoot
movie stars well I'm just so glad that I
could finally do a solo for all of you
should we talk about our interests or
hobbies why for so long hey there's a
Buffy Marathon going on downstairs
girl power vampires god blocker so what
the Neen disguises herself as a boy
which is pointless seeing elders clearly
women in the barricades in this version
and sacrifices her life to save her not
boyfriend on him
Oh we'll make the flower he of course
shows his devotion and respect for one
that loved him so much by immediately
sending a love letter to his real
sweetheart
hey three's a crowd but a nice
interception by Valjean who grabs a
letter and decides he should go down
there to protect Marius as he might be
the only hope his daughter has to living
a civil life given these social and
financial status of her father but not
before secretly freeing a captures aver
as he knows the rebels would most likely
kill him and strangely enough Crowe does
manage to act in this scene for a brief
moment it actually sounds like he gives
a damn once a thief forever a thief what
you want you always steal yes Valjean
you want to do you shoot me now there's
the autopilot I remember he has
Oscars pal Jonathan sings about how
important it is to protect Marius
describing him like a son a son he's
only known for a few minutes Oh
I here's my prayer
this is especially disrespectful to
original as a song was supposed to be
sung quietly and soothing here he belts
it out
I'm surprised she doesn't wake up the
entire army though and I suppose comb
wilkinson did much better he did much
better oh and his awkward lip movements
Jen was all for hilarious sounds like
this well okay maybe not every note was
perfect but I don't swallow a fish it's
still better than Jackman oh I don't
know Jackman never sounded like a
vomiting Canton reverse and now ladies
and gentlemen The Barking Wilkinsons one
the next day it looks like our
revolutionaries have no chance you have
no chance and one of the more touching
scenes the young boy Gavroche sacrifices
his life to fight for what he believes
in this leads to the final battle
between the soldiers and the rebels oh I
do hope it's all done close tight shot
so that nobody can figure out what's
going on
JaVale looks over the destruction and
gives a very tender moment handing over
his medal to the dead boy for his
bravery now this really begs the
question the symbol for lame is both the
movie and the stage production is the
child Cosette but shouldn't it be the
boy Gavroche I mean what does Cozzetto
do she looks scared and gets married
Gavroche is constantly active sacrifices
his life and has much more of a
character
why isn't he the symbol of the movie
because he can't do this
Valjean manages to escape with an
unconscious Marius and come across
Chabert waiting but chivay are so
confused by Valjean zhannar and kind
heart that not only does he let him go
but he questions his own morals is this
man what sort of devil is he to have me
caught in the child bun choose to let me
go for you God hearing crow debate
ethics is like watching a rock argue
with itself then define live in the
death of a thief tempted by yield at the
end of the chase play on the Lord
there's no
yeah really really that was the best
sound if they can come up with way to
kill him off with dignity yeah what
other cartoon sounds you think we can
put in there to up the drama oh hey I'm
sorry I couldn't resist
so Marius speaks with Valjean on the
Titanic and tells him that he wants
Marius to marry his daughter but he
can't be around for it because reasons
that are explained much much better in
the book his farm kazan 'this must be
fixed if he is caught she is disgraced
so Valjean vanishes and Marius does end
up marrying Cosette just as he finds out
the location of her father and thus goes
to see him on his death bed or chair oh
you
again miss me and isn't me or does a guy
who's about to die actually look better
than he did at the beginning of the
movie come with me with chains we'll
never mind
so Valjean finally passes the spirit of
Fantine is there to greet him and all
the souls who perished are joined again
next the sculpture that even Napoleon
called the giant eyesore
say is it me or has the room gotten a
lot less talented ah
hey guys I've been looking all over for
you are we gonna start this review or
what we would but well it's just the
week kind of um finished it already what
but but I never got a chance to do my
Russell Crowe voice I warned you I would
not give in to loosing like this it's
really cool to 4/6 a wall I wincing like
this I am Russell Crowe nobody TT to
throw is all what he is everyone knows
it man I'm sorry you had to find out
this way but a musician trying to learn
from Russell Crowe is like a public
speaker trying to learn from a mime I'm
sorry
Mali's judge this group of critical
notes to denigrate Russell Crowe and
make me feel like a turd all it would
take is just a minute or two but no they
won't let me sing Russell Crowe what
would you do
should I pick fights with random dudes
should I go start a crappy bad
and
would I be really hard to work with or
should I die by my own hand
and if I look like a flippity fool dem
people look like a floppity tool this is
not just a comedy bit either rising like
Russell Crowe or that
all escaped up on this wood I will
life today now
have my thumb I'll just have to find up
so final thoughts on the movie well I
think it's great it did a wonderful job
to update the musical as well as adapted
in a way that movie goers would enjoy it
has its problems here and there but I
think it's fantastic just to see it in
movie form well I thought it was
terrible
it's clumsy it's awkward it's full of
moment upon moment that doesn't work and
that commits the biggest crime to any
adaptation could it made me question
whether or not the material it's
adapting it was that damn great to begin
with you well as someone who enjoyed the
musical but acknowledges that it had
problems I think the film is kind of
similar some moments hit it right out of
the park and others don't even make it
up to that so I'm the hole I'm glad I
saw it but I don't think it's great wait
so it's like disliked and indifferent
well hell it's pretty much what the rest
of the critics of the world thought
there was no real majority consensus
it's one of those movies that is so hard
to get a fix on that pretty much
everybody had a different reaction to it
what the hell kind of a conclusion is
that we need some kind of opinion to
force on of us listen
do you hear the critic sing sing about
how they don't agree is a metaphor for
life when now's our big and speech is
free when upon this whole hunger you
need to pinch yourself because you must
be dreaming if that happens it never
does will you draw your own conclusion
or give up and follow me
it's also death to Justin Bieber it just
passed the day there's even some oyster
you're pretty
No
I got older
you see
now in your content oldest ear you lie
don't
Oh
ah home sweet home
hello critic we are waterbenders oh look
I'm not really into any New Age religion
pretty much they're all tell me I'm
still going to hell no no we're not here
for that
I'm Sokka and this is my sister Katara
well obviously
and what's your guys's story well I'm
the motherly emotional Center and I'm
funny uh uh well look can you two freaks
waterbend the hell out of here not until
you save the franchise franchise what
franchise there's a great evil that has
damaged our world and only you can
restore balance what are you talking
about
I'm Yakko I'm Wakko and I'm Joubert
oh my god won't this video ever end how
many endings are there well the only
reason we'd be doing this is if we had
something very important to tell you and
we do that charity drive is going to be
this Saturday on August 24 starting at
12 p.m. Central Time and going to 3 a.m.
central time going from Saturday to
Sunday we will be doing a charity drive
for one step at a time camp this is a
camp for children who have cancer a
place where kids can go to be kids again
to build good relationships good friends
and just have a wonderful time and we
want to support a cause that good as
much as we can any contribution you make
will be tax-deductible in all proceeds
minus the extra International shipping
charges will go directly to the charity
guys these are good people doing good
things and we hope you can find it in
your heart to show how much we
appreciate show your support for a
wonderful cause we hope to see you guys
there
you